[Music]
and that's not how it works news
submitted by Fuego rancheros a mayor
dumped a ton of trash on a clean Beach
for international clean-up day you gotta
do the photo-op
he couldn't find garbage of it pans
going downhill oh that's funny
am i right okay so this mayor I know I'm
right he's the mayor of jindo County
that Korea was in South Korea and it's
like a like one of the major islands
that they have so it's like the Hawaii
of South Korea oh cool so they're saying
that this mayor was saying that you like
there were 600 volunteers I really
wanted to participate in this there's a
mad enough to trash on this [ __ ]
[ __ ] and there was not there wasn't
any train people to pick up it's like
it's a beach it's a to clean matter
Parker bring the top truck and it's like
be politicians are the dumbest people on
the earth oh you got a do for the
photo-op exactly just like a youtuber
yeah I'll give you money to homeless
people check this out yeah why should I
give money at all most people wait
doesn't are candid [ __ ]
right I give this homeless man $100 look
at what a great person I am let's follow
them and see what happened or the
restaurant tipping I'm gonna make this
what you're so happy
boom thousand bucks yeah I kind of like
whose 15 grand oh my hands Bridget
sir Gertrude I like I like mr. B's going
into twitch Twitter's and going like
here's $100,000 can I say that I like
mr. B's and that's controversial for
some people why is it controversial well
my friend Jack Douglas was telling me
that he was he's poking fun I guess and
I was like I actually like mr. B's on
account of that he actually he does the
clickbait thing but he provides yeah I
like I like me here's the clicker I'm
gonna give away to waitress 15 grand and
then he does it who the [ __ ] does that
who the [ __ ] does picks up people in a
tank and ubers them right he delivers
every time do shake me to do something
he delivers he recently had a car lot
that he was like all right we're on sale
and then like he bought the whole entire
car lot for like a hundred grand right
and then um
she took over the car lot for the day
and he changed the prices of all the
cars to like 10 bucks $3 yeah and when
people came in they're like seriously I
could buy this car for 12 bucks Wow oh
yeah does he have some money so much
money to start that first I think that's
part of his brand deal
you know he makes he made it just like
from his videos and then he would spend
that money back into the videos you know
it just keeps like then he also does a
brand deal in the video sometimes but
that's where he got the cash oh yeah and
my friend Jack was this [ __ ] clown he
wasn't actually here but I just I like
mr. piece here he's somebody he's
somebody that I I like yeah but other
youtubers [ __ ] them yeah I even asked
yeah oh yeah especially I guess yeah
especially you guys in your personal
channels budgeter guys's personal
channels it has nothing to do with Jay
King news and you don't ever even think
about starting a channel you probably
not okay I will not tomorrow anyway back
to South Korea and mayor here who dumped
trash in a pristine Beach so we were
saying he was saying that since there
was no trash he decided to get other
coastal trash gathered from nearby area
smart so the 600 volunteers could have
something to clean yeah in this
International Coastal Cleanup Day so he
said that let me take the picture of the
other Beach I mean he could have just
sent the people to the other beaches
that needed to be [ __ ] clean don't
send a camera guy to [ __ ] it in Bali
beaches dude those things are nuts
looking it's very dirty oh yeah it's
like trash everywhere on Bali Beach but
it's such a nice paradise it is I loved
it there but you they they definitely
have a trash problem is it their trash
problem or is it their neighbors another
heat and it's washing up on their Shore
I don't know I was too busy on vacation
to worry about that [ __ ] I was like
giving a pineapple drink please thank
you way to turn your brain off I like
that I'm not gonna [ __ ] track the
garbage you know I will some Australian
entreprenuer guy would do who wear
sandals
I went to Bali on vacation but then I
discovered a new cause and I'm like wait
a vacation bro good guy though no sounds
like a loser he can't relax
but anyway so then the Mayor was saying
that 100 percent of the trash had been
cleaned up by the volunteers and that
none of it ended up in the ocean so it
didn't cause any secondary pollutions
stupid like we're gonna believe so they
wasted the city budget to bring the
trash even over they should have just
gone to the other Beach where they
picked up the trash and just picked it
up there but what if they have to do it
in Jindo cuz we're made he's mayor of
Jindo like one area of Jindo he's like
we don't want to clean up that area
that's okay they should have all worn
white gloves and if there's like dust
and you where they clean that up the
whole city yeah dude
basically all beaches look alike to me
what oh yeah basically basically right
what does that mean so once you live in
California Casey go to Hawaii once you
live in California where the waters
green and brown we're the wall right
what the but where the beaches like you
know what we got which is which is
considered nice for everyone else and
like the country yeah you've never been
to a tropical place yeah like you live
in Oklahoma be like wow this is
beautiful yes point being I went to
[ __ ] Costa Rica and we went to this
place like for my four hours inland and
then like went to their beach like that
was down south after that and it was
[ __ ] la beaches I was outraged it
wasn't a blue no what was the same
[ __ ] Rock they are h2 then see oh
those are not even yeah those are a
little different
but I will say Waikiki Beach it's the
same [ __ ] show that's pretty shitty
though I rather go to Santa Monica than
Waikiki I don't know about that no I'd
still go to whitey
wish to place the nice pictures there in
Oahu is that Waimanalo or Lanikai
there's a bunch of there's a lot of dope
yeah Sunset Beach North Shore yeah even
Maui I was like this looks like
California sorry deal with it
Hawaii it's okay no I did a lot is it
does Bahamas looks different okay so
you're only saying it looks yes that's
all I'm saying all day they will because
the water temperature is totally
different that's true quality he said
basically TIFF basic thing generally
it has the same elements a beach all has
the same sanded water sand water yeah
popping your lifeguard but I thought
sounds like saying basically white
people black people saying because
basically no I do think basically basis
very good that's how cool I am very very
progressive I like it
basically all hills are the same
basically basically yeah dude all cities
are the same that's pond in New York
basically you're not wrong basically all
our dicks big beautiful basically that's
wrong no they're all big endian nope
isn't there a show that they ring a bell
every time or a radio show they ring a
bell every time someone says basically
basically here in LA I forgot which one
it is anyway yeah so people were
outraged when they found out that this
trash was brought in no [ __ ] the
specimen is it a photo of this [ __ ]
okay because all we're gonna save a
picture of you Joe I pictured my old
Korean character like [ __ ] gone look
at the truck just look at the camera
trucks on the other side even
politicians are [ __ ] doing it for the
ground dude it's amazing they've been
doing it that's true there are the
original ones there's little ones
kissing babies and [ __ ] yeah don't kiss
my baby right there are the ones that
are like planting trees and I just
holding the shovel and they're like I'm
done just planting trees and cutting big
ribbons yeah taking pictures for that
okay I'm done
well you see so his office did apologize
we're sorry we got caught but they only
did it to quote raise awareness about
the seriousness of coastal it's always
that's always the reasons their cities
clean they needed like razor we made it
more dirty I wonder what kind of trash
they got - oh it was like styrofoam and
stuff there's still in the plastic bags
from Costco that's not content Darrell
Brandi yeah it was from like the other
coastal trash guys what a waste of 600
volunteers time you know what politician
you know politician that actually did
charity was Jimmy Carter really Habitat
for Humanity he would build houses and
he was there like the whole [ __ ] time
and [ __ ]
I don't know much
about that president for ha'la'tha first
time he was a peanut farmer don't you
know what else he came from I thought
that was George Washington Carver
could be yeah or George Washington the
same things yeah it's come on who's that
that's the president never even heard of
George Washington Carver who's that no
no no he was black he couldn't been
president yeah yeah I used the peanut
butter man he was he was uh yeah how do
you guys know this basically this was
using like eighteen hundreds or
something no he was like yeah he had no
shot at being proud the whole
conversation ya know cuz I didn't know
Jimmy Carter was a peanut farmer I don't
know Hamilton was turning to musical how
about that and I didn't know that he was
black either neither Hamilton's black
yes wait what the [ __ ] were we talking
about a Korean guy yes you guys do any
volunteer work no [ __ ] no we did we have
when I was a kid I volunteered for
Nickelodeon's the big help and I pledged
like 15,000 hours and then I got bored
in 30 minutes we did the hash tag lunch
bag with our with our friend that oh
really yeah it's about life I've done a
lot of but we can't work no the oh yeah
when you when you're a part of a church
or a cult they make you do a lot of free
[ __ ] yeah when I was in church I did a
lot of shows oh really
yeah I'm gonna church at I did my I did
my first communion and then I did my
confirmation yeah my soul is saved with
God what's the difference between Church
and a cult you say not that much it's
just people right I thought it's just if
you have a location to meet out or you
meet in the woods I feel like nobody's
your life like religion or like churches
more like they sound the same
it's kind of like it's kind of line has
pun you could do whatever you want and
then you could come back it's my god
well it's like a boyfriend that's not
controlling and in a cult is like one of
those your friends are gonna turn
against you so just cut ties with them
like yeah it's like oh it's like a
boyfriend that's obsessive and
controlling that's the difference
love you like how [ __ ] weird is it
that like we're almost at the time where
we're all gonna go get trees or plastic
trees and put them in the middle of our
living room and cover them in lights
I'm excited about that I am too but
that's the protocol to scold [ __ ] man
that's called session because it's like
[ __ ] weird weird ceremony everyone
get a gift it's very like and you don't
even really have to know what the [ __ ]
anything about Jesus or any of that [ __ ]
to participate you just thought you just
full heartedly do it yeah you full
heartedly buy plastic of different weird
colors and a pop around the house and
lights nail socks up to the wall yeah
thanks again like doing it distres are
you gonna nail the socks on the wall and
we're gonna film what can you leave I
will put your name on it right okay you
guys are weird
if I was an alien I landed here I'd be
like these guys are [ __ ] weird I'm
out but I love it I love that cult
though I know they'll never get to know
the feeling of Christmas
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]